Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-winning actor
and "New York Times"
best-selling author
you know from films
such as "Interstellar"
and "Dallas Buyers Club."
He returns as Buster Moon
in "Sing 2,"
which premieres
in theaters December 22nd.
Let's take a look.
-[ Bell dings ]
-[ Gasps ]
-Maybe it's like room service?
-[ Banging ]
-Open up or you're dead, Moon!
-Okay, it's not room service.
-You and your dumb friends
better not be hiding in there!
-What are we gonna do?
-Guys, we just
got to be brave now.
-Are you saying we should
fight these thugs?
-No, no.
They'll beat us to a pulp.
-[ Bang ]
-[ All gasp ]
-We're gonna put this show on,
whether Crystal likes it or not!
But first...we're gonna
jump out that window.
-What?!
-I'm beginning
to like this guy.
-Please welcome back to the show
Matthew McConaughey, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
-Welcome back!
-How you doing, Seth?
-There's a -- You know,
over the years,
I've come to expect
a certain level of excellence
from you in film.
-Okay.
-But, you know, now you are --
This is the first time that I've
been sitting across from you
where you are a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let me tell ya. I said it
a little bit backstage.
There was this lull where
I think people were looking
for exactly the book you wrote.
You couldn't have known that,
probably, when you were
sitting down to write it,
'cause I think you probably
wrote a story authentic to you.
You wrote about your life.
-And then COVID came along,
and we said,
"Ooh, our release date
is October. COVID is coming."
There was talk about
moving the date.
The elections were there.
My feeling and the team's
feeling was, "Look.
Let's lean into it,
with elections,
with all the mud-slinging,
with COVID.
People are gonna want
some good news."
You know what I mean?
People were gonna want to hear
some things
that are about the approach
to life, not the product.
The process
and the approach to life
and how to get some satisfaction
not only for me,
that I think we can all get.
-And I think that everybody,
having watched you
over the years, they thought,
"Man, if I could get in
on Matthew McConaughey's
approach to life,
I think I'd be
in a lot better place."
-I hope so.
Look, it's not all mine.
I've stolen a lot of stuff.
You know what I mean?
-It does sound so much
better coming from you.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah. Yeah.
Yeah, the old voice.
The old voice makes the medicine
taste better sometimes.
-I heard from a lot of people
they read it and loved it.
And then I heard from equally,
if not more, people,
if there's anything you want
to listen to the audio of,
it is "Greenlights."
It's Matthew's book,
that you read.
And how was it actually --
You know,
obviously,
writing it is one thing,
but then
when you got to read it --
-Then I got to
sort of perform it.
And there's a lot of
different voices
'cause of my travels
around the world.
I'm doing the voices of...
[Australian accent]
Australians along the way.
There's a great story
in there called
"Sydney
in the Rear-view Mirror."
It's a great black comedy.
[Normal voice]
But I actually -- You know,
I thought that we'd scheduled
four days to record it.
And I recorded it
in eight hours one day. Whoop.
-Wow.
-And I just --
Because I've told the stories
so many times,
I knew where the characters
came up
and what the intentions were
and sort of how
the act 1, act 2, act 3
of each story was set up.
And it was a ball doing it,
and we knocked it out,
and people are saying
they enjoy it.
-And then,
when you were recording it,
was there ever anything
where you thought,
"Oh, I wish I'd written it
a different way"
or was it just,
"No, this is great"?
-No, by that time, I mean,
I had spent over a year editing,
so every punctuation,
every font,
everything in the book
was exactly as I wanted it.
So there was no going back.
And I didn't want to go back.
-Perfect.
-So it was good.
-That seems like
another piece of wisdom.
-"There's no going back.
And I couldn't go back.
And I didn't want to go back."
-Another thing that's changed
since the last time I saw you --
you are now a football-club
owner, but European soccer.
You own a soccer team now.
Here you go.
Austin. Is it Austin FC?
-Austin FC.
The Austin Football Club.
-Now, I realize --
-Verde! Listos!
-I realize that I put this up
like I was about to show
a soccer team,
and, instead, it's just you
with a bongo drum of sorts.
-This is a djembe.
This is our opening game
at Q2 Stadium.
-Alright.
-And this suit is exactly
our colors of our team.
I got this suit made
three years ago,
and this is
less than a year ago,
so I held onto this suit
for this night,
to come out with my djembe.
Bring your drum.
Drum is our instrument.
Actually, we'll allow
any instrument in the stadium.
But it was --
We have a chant, "Verde,"
which is Spanish for "green."
And the response to that
is, "Listos,"
which is Spanish for "ready."
So, the whole crowd,
I got them going.
Going, "Verde." "Listos."
"Verde." "Listos."
And the only challenge with this
night was, two years later,
hoping that that suit
would fit me,
'cause I hadn't tried it on
in two years.
-And how'd it go?
-It worked out.
-There you go.
And let me say, I think anyone
who's a fan of a team
would just want some enthusiasm
from their owner,
and I think they got
what they wanted
when that's your owner
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, we showed a clip
from "Sing."
This is "Sing 2."
Five years between the films.
You've got three kids.
They're a little bit older.
Have they grown into
being a "Sing" audience?
Have they grown out of
Are they just thrilled
to hear their dad's voice?
-They're still
in the "Sing" audience.
Look, the first one was
basically one of the first films
I've ever done that they could
be an audience member to.
-Yeah.
-I mean, for years --
That's one of the reasons
I did it, 'cause it was like,
"What's your kids's
favorite movie you've done?"
I was like, "They haven't
seen any of them.
I haven't sat them down in
front of 'True Detective' yet."
It's gonna open up
a lot of questions.
-You're like,
"This is gonna answer
a lot of questions about life."
-So, we give them
"Sing 2," "Sing 1."
They dig it.
I'm cooler around the --
I got some street cred at the
dinner table after "Sing 1."
"Sing 2," they were around
the process of making it.
They were around
the process of recording.
They toured the studios in Paris
and got to know Garth,
the director.
And they weren't as surprised
to see my voice
come out of a koala's head.
-Yeah.
-But they still were
a little surprised.
I remember sitting there,
even with "Sing 2" --
I'm sitting where you are.
My kids are right here
to the right.
Buster Moon comes on the screen,
and my voice comes out.
They look at Buster.
They look at me.
And, all of a sudden, they go,
"Ha ha!"
And I go, "Yeah." Yeah.
-What about --
This is -- You know,
obviously, it's very exciting
that you're in this film,
don't get me wrong, but Bono.
-Bono!
-Making his animated-film debut.
-Graced us with his presence.
-Yeah. That's really exciting.
-Really badass.
-Who does Bono play in the film?
-He plays Clay Calloway.
He's the rock 'n' roller
who left the gig,
who had a personal tragedy
that took him away
from music,
never wanted to perform again.
So, in that way, it's a story
of resurrection and rebirth.
We have to go get him
to bring him from his refuge
to get him on the stage
in our show,
if our show
is gonna go on at all.
And if it doesn't go on,
I'll probably get killed
by that wolf you saw.
-No spoilers, no spoilers.
-So we got to pull him out
and get him on the stage.
-You got any holiday plans?
-Yes.
-Alright.
What do you got going on?
-Going to Texas.
-Okay.
-But this time,
we have my wife,
Camila's, family coming in.
-Great.
-So, it's been four years,
I think,
since we've all been together.
So Christmas holidays
will be extra family.
Air mattresses will be blown up.
-Okay.
-Three -- Some twin beds.
And it will be some late nights,
because the Brazilians do their
Christmas on Christmas Eve.
-Okay.
-So you eat late.
Then you open presents
at midnight, which --
Then, the next day,
you're opening presents all day,
'cause my mom likes to see
every single present
opened up one by one.
And my brother's coming,
who loves to just put meat
on the smoker.
Not because he loves the way
it tastes.
Just because it takes
longer to cook.
And he figures
if you're eating by midnight,
no matter what it tastes like,
everyone likes it
'cause they're so damn hungry.
-Yeah.
-Oh, that's a very smart move
for a chef, yeah.
-Yeah.
-My thought of people who run
the smoker is always
they just want to use it
as an excuse
for not having to do
anything else.
-That's it.
"Hey, I'm tending the brisket."
"What are you doing?"
"I just checked it.
Checked it an hour ago.
I better not walk away, though."
-"Could dry right out."
-Yeah.
-I want to congratulate you
on something.
"Hollywood Reporter" named you
Philanthropist of the Year.
Congratulations on that.
That must mean a lot.
-Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Your organization, foundation,
just keep livin, is it --
You've been doing this
for a while now.
-We've been doing that 12 years.
-12 years.
-Which Camila and I founded it.
And we help at-risk student --
high-school students
in Title I schools in America.
We're in over 40 schools now.
They meet twice a week.
It's a safe place for them
to go after school.
They make a physical-fitness
goal, whether that's,
"I want to make the soccer team,
so I need to get in shape"
or whether that's,
"I need to lose 3 pounds
so I can fit in my prom dress,"
we'll help them meet that goal.
Nutritional goals.
They do community service.
They all do community service
in their communities.
And the halo
over the whole foundation,
which is really cool,
is gratitude.
We all sit around
after every class,
and everyone sits in a circle
and has to share,
out loud, something they are
thankful for in their life.
And that's kind of
the coolest part about it.
-That's really great.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I know there had been
some talk --
You know, obviously, you're
making a difference with that.
There was some talk
about you maybe embarking
on a political career, maybe
running for governor of Texas.
You've since said
you're not gonna do that.
-Yep.
-Was that something that --
Was your family on the side of,
"hey, maybe that's not for you,"
or were they disappointed
you decided not to do it?
-My daughter was
a little disappointed.
She thought
it would be really cool.
But she's 11. I mean, she --
-Yeah, not quite
campaign-manager level.
-Wasn't ready to hire her
for that position yet.
The family -- Look, all
my decisions now going forward,
I share them
with my wife, Camila.
She knows me as well as anybody.
She asks me the hard questions.
She makes sure that
I'm convicted the right ways
within the decisions
I'm gonna make.
They were --
would have been on with it.
They were ready
if that was what Popeye,
or what Matthew,
was really wanting to do.
So we discussed it
for quite a long time,
and she knew
I was seriously considering.
The whole family knew
I was seriously considering it.
It got to the point
where I said,
"You know what? No."
After living in a mind of
"maybe I will" for over a year,
I said, "No, it's not
the right time for me right now.
It's not my embassy.
I'm gonna see what I can do
more in an informal space
as a leader."
-Well, I'm not worried
about you
making a difference
no matter where you are.
And I really appreciate
you spending time with us today.
Thank you so much.
-Seth, I appreciate it.
-That's Matthew McConaughey.
"Sing 2" opens in theaters
December 22nd.